[Applause]
thank you very much mr. president I
would also like to recognize some
special guests that we have first lady
arrow ahmed is here please recognize her
I believe your son has also joined us
here and his name is Chabad talabani
we have the Minister of State for
women's affairs micelle Shaklee
the Minister of Labour mister Solly
and the Minister of Technology Miss
Boutrous
we would now like to open the floor for
questions please go I'd like to give
priority to Columbia students good
morning my name is Casey Barnett's I'm a
student with the business school here at
Columbia I'm also the director of cami D
a research and training institute in
Southeast Asia your excellency you
mentioned that the Iraqi Constitution is
the best in the region yet article 7 of
the Constitution forbids bat party
members from becoming part of the
political system now most people became
bad party members to go to college or
get a job wouldn't it be smarter for
your government to focus on the leaders
of the bat party rather than the
rank-and-file must have a seat now
looked at across this you
we also should take this occasions too
you can just line up behind the
microphones to ask questions this is not
true not all bosses are forbidden from
participating all only the criminals and
special rank of buses are prevented but
the big majority of them are permitted
they are posted as Iraqis they can
participate in the democratic process
and there even many of them are still in
job in universities in schools in
departments in administration and the
only who are prevented from that those
who committed crimes according to law
next question sir my name is Garth
Stewart and I'm a general study student
here at Columbia and I was in the 3rd
Infantry Division in 2003 and I was a
very active participant in the
liberation of Iraq let me say let me
just ask put the microphone up I so that
you can be heard more clearly is this
alright is acceptable if I just bend my
head a little bit I was in the 3rd
Infantry Division an active participate
in the liberation of Iraq and I have to
say it's an honor to hear you speak here
today sir
my question is in your speech you
referred to a new Iraq and I wanted to
know do you ever plan on seeking refere
some sort of reform in the Middle East
as it concerns other governments that
aren't so enlightened is what Iraq is
becoming
of course for the this for this reason
many of our neighbors are very are not
happy and satisfied because a democratic
federal stable Iraq will expire all
people of Middle East to free themselves
from dictatorship and to enjoy democracy
for that I think you were in Iraq he
observed that many neighbors are not
satisfied with liberation of Iraq or
having democracy and democratic rights
in Iraq hi I'm mr. constant my name is
Minh all aalam and I'm a student in the
engineering school what will it take in
the future for Iraq to have a separate
political identity not linked to the
United States
I think we are an independent country
and Iraqi people is proud to be
independent and we are always struggled
to be an independent country but we are
in need to kind of co-operation and
alliances in this global of we are
suffering living in it and this
globalization is demanding that
cantonese must look kind of cooperation
and coordination among them next
question mr. president my name is on Tom
Laden on a journalism student here and
as I understand it you have the very
admirable policy of not signing
execution warrants which Iraqi courts
pass up to your office and delegate this
Duty to a deputy and I also understand
that this is because the Democratic
patriotic alliance of Kurdistan is
obliged under treaties you signed not to
endorse the death penalty uh I think
that's wholly admirable but I was
wondering if you thought it was a
problem or setup or precedent for the
president of a sovereign country of Iraq
to be bound by regional obligations not
to fulfill sections of his office thank
you well you know we are in Iraq now
enjoying democracy we have different
parties and groups from left extreme
left to extreme right of course
different attitudes I am as a lawyer I
signed an international appeal against
the death penalty and I'm respecting my
signature for that I am enable
even even I said if I was one day
obliged between my principal to choose
between my principals and the post I
will leave the post and keep my
protecting my principles I know that
perhaps the next president will not be
in the same way and on the same kind of
thinking but it's my believe and I
cannot deny my signature next question
hello mr. president my name is Patrick
Liam I'm a student of Japanese
literature here in the Graduate School
Arts and Sciences and I wanted to thank
hear your speech and also welcome you to
Columbia during your speech you spoke
about the kindness and generosity of
American troops and with that attitude I
was wondering how you interpret an event
like what happened at Abu Ghraib yeah
that was in everyone if something was
very bad happened that some American
soldiers simple soldiers violated the
human rights but I'd like to remind you
I believe as a prison in Iraq when
thousands and thousands of Iraqis were
executed it was a prison of tens of
thousands of Iraqi visited this prison
and suffered worst kind of torture and
violating of human rights for that of
course we condemned what happened
against Iraqis because we want to have
the human rights everywhere in Iraq and
human rights must be respected by
Americans Iraqis everyone but when
Iraqis remember treason of Abu Ghraib
they are remembering thousands and
thousands of their murders who were
killed in that prison next question mr.
president my name is marina Donahue
masters of law student from Ireland in
light of the Constitution ization and
the problems that have shown in Iraq
what is the possibility of the complete
secularization of Iraq in light of the
road that religious law plays and
religious diversity
sinara well we couldn't reach a secular
state handled personal scale there was a
kind of compromise as I told you in my
speech there is of course we have strong
the Islamic parties the word even some
of them were asking for an Islamic
Republic
for example we couldn't reach agreement
with a group of Sunni Arabs about the
article which says that Islam is a
source for loss the insistence that is
must be the main source of all laws we
repeated it we tried to reach a kind of
compromise that we could in the same
time respect the democratic principles
and respect Islam as a religious of the
majority of Iraq of course it's
respecting other religions like
Christianity like a CDs like Sabbath's
and others which mentioned in this
constitution next question
hello mr. president my name is Shirley
shavit I'm the director of an
International Department the biggest
women organisation in Israel first of
all it was a great honor to hear you and
to listen to what you said and I'm very
concerned and I would like to ask your
attitude regarding the State of Israel
regarding the future coexistent with
iraq and i think we have a lot in common
regarding our concern for world
democracy as well is there a Qaeda
threat to the whole world
thank you very much well thank you for
your question we are in Iraq committed
to our member an active member and
founder member of the League Arab League
we are part of the Arab world Iraq
participated on all the summit Arab
summits the last one which was in Beirut
decided that
adopted proposal presented by then
prince now King Abdullah of Saudi Arabia
according to this proposal there is some
kind of promise if Israel will respect
all resolutions part passed by the
United Nations and recognize the
existence of a peaceful Palestinian
state the Arab countries will normalize
relations with Israel and will have full
kind of contact with them it's now up to
Israeli people and Israeli government to
decide to accept this proposal of King
Abdullah and then I think everything
will be normal and open yes
I'm karmak McGee I'm his master's
student at the School of International
and public affairs for come to let us
ahead and fig tree at Columbia I were
pregnant um being a Middle Eastern
specifically from Lebanon I just want to
let everyone know that any change in the
Middle East is better than the status
quo so some people who argue at this
point in time so some people who argue
about whether the US should have gone in
or out I think the change was very
important however I do have a concern
and your speech you said to repeat a
number of times that you are killing and
capturing the terrorists
I was just wondering these people strive
and breed on the Brill on the blood of
their martyr brothers do you think that
by killing and capturing these
terrorists you will be solving the
problem of insurgencies because I find
that this is only addressing the symptom
of terrorism then rather than the
radical cause of terrorism so what
measures are being done by the Iraqi
government to address social welfare and
education yes what's killing is not in
FA but don't forget we are killing those
terrorists in defense of ourself they're
attacking us and we are killing them
this is very important point you muscle
take it in consideration when they are
coming for example to occupy a town we
are not ready to surrender to them we
are going to resist to liberate the town
and we are killing those who are at
trying to impose the rule by force on
the people this is one second we believe
that there must be a comprehensive plan
for facing terrorism this plan must be
political economic media public opinion
relation with diplomacy many things out
and I think those who came publishers in
Iraq are different groups some different
some groups are from al-qaeda and from
for domestic fundamentalist Islamists
who came and declared the war of
annihilation they openly said in
Statesman that are killing all cheats
and can consider all she is out of Islam
and also they killing all kurds because
there are lots of analysis of america
well a group coming to an eye on them
declared the war of annihilation what do
you want for us maybe gotta kiss them
this is one second second as you said
any change in Middle East is very very
important and especially the Democratic
Change is very important it will change
the Middle East and those who are afraid
from new Iraq they are afraid from
democracy and from democratization in
Middle East mr. president it's an honor
to have you here today my name is Andrew
Monahan and I'm with the School of
International and public affairs we
learned from the American experience as
the oldest democracy in the world that
one of the true potential threats of the
federalist system is civil war what
assurances do give the world that iraq
can become a true federalist democracy
that will stay together thank you
well it depends on the will of iraqi
people it's also mentioned in
constitutions that Iraqi people through
their free will decide if they want to
have
government's a kind of fishing that
Federation with democracy are necessary
for building a multi nation country and
without Federation and democracy it's
impossible to imagine a united strong
Iraq with all these different
nationalities religious etc mr.
president my name is Rachel McMillan I
am in the Columbia College one of the
main reasons that President Bush gave us
for going to war in Iraq and for
Operation Iraqi Freedom was the
allegation of nuclear weapons which we
now know didn't exist now of course in
Iran in North Korea we see large nuclear
weapon arsenals being developed as well
do you think that if it was a basic
human rights issue that we would have
gone to Iraq in the first place or was
that lie actually needed to garner
international support and attention
well I think there were mass destruction
arms according to our information our
own information there was massive
chemical weapons which was used against
Jewish people in Halabja against Iranian
sand against south of Iraq and there was
also biological weapons also now we are
discovering graves for example that
contained the children between 6 to 1 to
6 here some other 6 to 12 some 12 to 18
wishing that there was a kind of a
exercise of the chemical and the
biological weapons which we were sure
that there were chemical weapons and
there were biological weapons but it
could hide them you know Iraq is a big
country
this is one the second I think
liberating 27 27 million Iraqis and
building a democratic center in Middle
East was deserving to be to participate
in this war of liberation I don't forget
that this is a tradition of American
people America participated in the
Second World War first world war in in
Asia liberating of one Sun in welcome in
many places that's the glorious people
of the world they have their own
responsibility to pay the price of it
although I am sorry for all kinds of
American casualties yes
as then I'm international student in the
School of Engineering from Turkey so I
wonder where exactly meant in the
beginning of your speech with Kurdistan
partner where you meant exactly the
speech of England beginning of speech as
cutest at Curtin is a country I didn't
create it
God created if you in Turkey denying it
it doesn't mean that's not existing this
even at the time of Kemal Pasha Ataturk
was recognized it go back to the first
building of Turkish national assembly
you'll see on the world the list of
military Kurdistan milord luckily this
country is now a part of it in Iraq this
part of Iraq is officially recognized we
have a regional government of Kurdistan
and this original we have also a
national assembly of kuru son that we
are recognizing in Iraq we don't want to
interfere in your own refers if you
don't want to recognize its appeal but
we have good son as a part of Iraq yes
welcome mr. president my name is Nick
Jennings I'm an undergraduate student in
the engineering school you spoke a
little bit about the Constitution in
your speech and I was wondering if you
could address what the major impediments
are to having some kind of consensus I
know you said not there's never a case
where everyone can be happy but what do
you see as being the major problems from
having I guess widespread consensus the
major problems was first relation
between state and religion
some people say insisted that Iraq must
be an Islamic regime and some people
wanted to say that Islam is the main
source of the laws in Iraq it was one of
the big shifts in the discussion second
was the some are Sunni Arabs refused
Federation for the south they recognized
the Federation for Kurdistan because
they said Federation is existing since a
long time
cool son it is a reality to de facto but
they denied right of having a regional
government for the people of the south
they search about the relation between
Iraq and Arab world what we have agreed
with the Secretary General of Arab
League was Iraq is a founding member an
active member of the League of Arab
League's and a committed to the Charter
and this resolution decisions of the
Arab League some people want to say that
Iraq is a part of Arab nation by denying
the existence of clickers convenience
turkmens as seniors etc that was the
three main issues in the way of reaching
a consensus on the Constitution yes mr.
president
my name is hala al Shariff I am an Iraqi
Fulbright student I major in health
policy and if you allow me sir I will
speak in English and then give me the
pleasure of talking and ever in Arabic
to our president as an iraqi arab muslim
shia woman i feel so privileged to stand
here and talk to you because this is the
first time i have a chance to talk a
president and i have passed my 40 years
i never wanted to speak to the president
before but I'm greatly honored to be
here and talk to you I'm doing masters I
left the family behind I'm doing it
basically for Iraq I want to go back as
soon as possible and try to do something
and participate with all the good
efforts I have the worry being a woman
being you know I don't know what's going
to happen to the Constitution the draft
but I do acknowledge that there are
women leadership I mean the existence of
a first lady here is something we would
have never thought it would happen and
the lady Minister how can we be
what assurances could we have in light
of what you have said about the
dominance of the cleric very strong
fundamental attitude towards women
participation in Iraq what is our
assurance if we go back thank you very
much no no I am proud I am proud to have
you with us here and Iraqi woman from
City section of Iraq and proud to to see
lady like you express his attitude very
frankly I'd like to tell you that
according institution many rights of
women is ensured equality among men and
women the right to have 25% of
parliament from women of course this
will reflect in government now we have
about six ministers ladies six ladies
minister Rebecca will have the beauty
Prime Minister a lady also and we have
many members in the ladies in the
National Assembly
and also we indirectly put in the
Constitution that this Constitution will
respect the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights which had lot of rights of
women in it and also the women are free
to choose in their marriage and the
divorce and likely divorce of course to
choose they want to go to civil court or
to go to the mosque when were lasting
and of course you know my dear sister
you know that in Iraq we have now a
stronger movement but I must be honest
with you they are not denying the
fundamental rights of women so there are
some kind of differences as you know but
we have to try to to reach compromise on
it Allah you succeed in what will do
thank you except the Greek greeting some
other Iraqi fulbrighters who are
studying in Texas Massachusetts Michigan
this is a great opportunity to be
to give all of them my regards thank you
my love
the
the president has time for just two more
questions yes my name is Emily Roth I am
an international undergraduate student
in Columbia College mr. peasant it is
known that you have distanced yourself
from the Kurdish independence movement
for the sake of working with different
ethnic groups during the process of
rebuilding Iraq what I'm wondering is
what your stand is going to be in the
future concerning the Kurdish
independence movement my girlfriend I
had my struggle all my life I was
struggling for a democracy in Iraq and
Kurdish right within the framework of of
Iraq I was convinced that Kurdish people
who fortunately divided in the Middle
East has the right to self-determination
like others but it's impossible today to
think about independent Kurdistan I
never asked for independent Kurdistan
because I know it's impossible to I can
give you an example now let us imagine
to tomorrow the National Assembly of
person decide declaring independence if
our neighbors didn't I don't fight us
but close the border how I can come back
to you you again to be here in this
present for that we must be realistic
we must struggle for what is possible
achievable of demands of college people
and we think the best is democracy for
Iraq and Federation within the framework
of Iraq as part of Kurdistan rose thank
you very much
yes thank you for coming today my name
is Christopher Ray and I'm a graduate
student at the School of Social Work
concentrating international Social
Welfare um in your speech you said that
there was no specific timeframe to pull
the troops out of Iraq so my question
for you is in your opinion what exactly
we need to take place in order for our
troops to come home thank you I think
the best thing we can do is that to
train our forces and to prepare Iraqi
Armed Forces for combating again
terrorism and the defending this
sovereignty and depends of the country
and of course there must be always kind
of consultation and negotiation among
coalition forces and Iraqi to reach
agreement when it will be necessary to
remove but I think when annual starting
a noble mission it must be finished
successfully thank you very much mr.
president let me just say that it is a
great pleasure and honor for us to have
you here today and to spend this time it
is interesting we're working on a
project as part of the world leaders
forum to have women from the Iraqi
legislature come and speak at Columbia
at some point in this year this of
course with the issues that have been
raised speak to great questions in the
United States and the world issues of
multilateralism issues of democracy
issues of free markets issues of
intelligence
these are questions that are being
debated throughout America at this time
as you know for you to come here and
spend this time with us and to answer
questions so forth rightly and freely we
deeply appreciate and thank you all for
coming to join thank you
[Applause]